everyone has mental health which means  it is everybody's business  one in four of us will experience a  mental health need each year in england  mental ill health can affect anyone but  is more likely to affect certain groups  these can include but are not exclusive  to people from black asian and minority  ethnic groups  people who identify as lgbtq plus people  who are homeless  people who have a learning disability or  a physical health problem  carers and victims of domestic abuse  other factors such as poverty poor  housing unemployment social isolation  and traumatic events can also affect  mental health  you